안녕하세요 디슬르트 알렉입니다. AI가 요즘에 가장 관심사하죠. 그리고 이제는 많이 그냥 현실이 되어버려 가고 있네요.
AI 시대에 정말 이게 직업적으로 안전한지 이것이 모두의 관심사가 되어버린 상황입니다.
특별히 이제 개발자 쪽으로 저는 꽤 오랜 시간 이 업계에 있었고 앞으로 어떻게 될까 라는 생각을 좀 하게 되고
좀 전체적인 흐름 가운데 지금 그리고 앞으로에 대한 얘기를 좀 드려보고요.
그리고 바이브 코딩으로 제가 최근에 외주 개발을 작게 해본 경험 그리고 어떤 공부를 해야 될지 이런 생각을 좀 나눠보고자 합니다.
좀 오래된 얘긴데요. 제가 대학교 때 교수님으로부터 천공카드라는 얘기를 들었어요. 지금도 뭐 잊을 수 없는 얘기인데
저는 한참 그때 시어너를 공부하고 있었고요. 그 교수님은 낫대 얘기를 하시면서 낫대는 천공카드로 프로그램을 했다 그 얘기가 찾아보니까
요런 이미지였습니다. 요런 이미지. 뭔가 오래말 카드 같기도 하고 뭔가 펀치를 뚫는 것 같은 그 뚫어서 어떤 기계에 넣으면 얘가 판독을 하고 어떤 프로그램을
구동을 해줬다고 하더라고요. 그래서 만약에 여기 잘못되면 이 버그 하나를 수정하기 위해서 다시 처음부터 끝까지 다 찍고 다시 줄을 서서
그 천공카드를 기계에 넣어서 결과를 받는. 그래서 한번 하려면 며칠이 걸리기도 하고 그 디벅인 과정도 꽤 오래 걸렸다.
과연 그게 프로그램이 가능할까랄 정도로 굉장히 의문이 들었지만 어쨌든 그러한 시절도 있었다라는 아주 아주 오래된 정말
과거 얘기인데 음 저는 요 경험은 해보진 않았고 시어너로 뭘 만들었냐면 도스 풀그림이라는 것을 만들어 본 경험이 있어요.
그러니까 이게 어떤 거냐면요 이것은 메뉴를 만들고 직접 하나하나 이 메뉴에 대한 기능을 또 개발하는 겁니다. 그래서 상당히 많은 시간이 걸려서 이런 프로그램 만들어요.
이렇게 겉에만 만들기에도 굉장히 시간이 많이 걸려요. 그러니까 이 프로그램 동일하지 않지만 이런 형태를 만들어 가는 것이 굉장히 많은 일 중에 하나였습니다.
그때는 그러다가 제가 윈도우를 윈도우 프로그램을 만나고 굉장히 충격을 받았어요. 윈도우 프로그램에서의 어떠한 화면 하나를 만드는 게 예를 들면
이런 비주얼 스튜디오 툴을 통해서 만드는데요. 예를 들면 이렇게 화면 하나를 만들고 프로그램을 딱 띄우는데 이런 이런 띄우는 것이 몇 분도 안 걸리고 1시간 이내로 이렇게 만드는 거예요.
과거의 도스에서 만들려면 이거 하나하나를 픽셀을 처리하고 그리고 그것을 반복하면서 한 땀 한 땀 만들었다면 이것은 여기에 위치에다가 이런 기능을 가져다 놓고 가져다 놓고 가져다 놓고 해서
뭐 빌드만 딱 하면은 이 일종의 화면에 딱 만들어지는 거예요. 그때 저는 상당히 충격을 받았습니다. 어 그럼 우리가 하는 게 뭐야
그때도 그런 말을 했어요. 우리가 할 게 뭐야. 왜냐하면 이걸 만드는 것 자체도 프로그램에 많은 비중이었기 때문에 그랬죠.
그래서 그때도 상당히 충격적이었고 그리고 이제 앱 시대가 왔죠. 윈도우 시대 한참 지나서 나왔지만 스마트폰 앱에서
앱이 나왔을 때 저는 굉장히 흥분하고 재미있게 느꼈던 거는 대부분의 모든 기능이 다 제공이 되는 거예요.
api 나 sdk 안에서 api 로 다 쓸 수 있게 제공이 되는 거예요. 모든 기능이 그건 정말 대박이죠. 전화과는 화면도 만들 수 있고
뭐 메시지를 보낼 수 있는 것도 만들 수 있고 다 만들 수 있는 거예요. 스마트폰 앱으로 그때도 충격이었던 게
어 이렇게 api 레벨로 sdk 안에서 모든 것을 다 만들 수 있게 해준다. 왜냐하면 이때 이 과거에 보면은 어떤 프로그램을 만든다는 것은
알고리즘을 만들고 그 알고리즘에 그것을 직접 다 구현하는 관점이었어요. 이때까지만 해도 윈도우 프로그램이다 하더라도 거의 구현을 해야 됐고
물론 윈도우 api 도 있어서 좀 쉽게 쉽게 화면을 만들 수 있었지만 이렇게 모든 것이 정말 만들으라고 제공되는 수준은 아니었다는 거예요.
자 이때까지만 해도 시어너 또는 c++만 해도 메모리 를 관리합니다.
그래서 전공자들이 컴퓨터 구조를 그렇게 공부를 하는 이유가 이 메모리에 대한 이해가 있어야 어느 정도 프로그램을 짤 수 있기 때문이고 지금도 물론 메모리 관리를 철저하는
어 프로그램들 그렇게 구동되는 것들이 꽤 많습니다. 하지만 대부분이 이제 잡아
뭐 파이선 이런 거 하죠. 메모리 관리 하지 않아요. 메모리는 jvm 이라든가 일어나서 자체적으로 가비지 컬렉션이나 이런 걸로 처리가 됩니다.
처리가 되는 상황이 있지만 개발자가 직접 메모리 관리는 하지 않는다라는 것은 굉장히 큰 변화였고
또 이런 식으로 화면을 아주 쉽게 만든다는 것도 상당히 큰 변화였어요. 그러니까 개발자의 생산성은
높아지는 쪽으로 계속 진화되고 발전되고 있었던 것이고 이런 앱도 사실 이런 안드로이드 스튜디오 이런 걸 열어서
어떤 여러 가지를 붙여서 바로 빌드하면 어느 정도 그렇게 어렵지 않게 앱을 만들 수가 있어요. 그러니까
책 같은 것도 많이 나와있죠. 스마트폰 앱 만들기 이런 것 잘 따라하면 만들 수가 있습니다.
이렇게 과거를 생각을 보면 무조건 쉬워지는 방향 그리고 개발을 생산성이 높아지는 방향
이런 쪽으로 계속 진화했다라는 거예요. 물론 이 진화의 속도가 이렇게 가다가 이 ai 시대에서는 정말 획기적으로 바뀐 거죠.
이때만에도 개발을 공부해야 됐고 개발을 당연히 공부해야 됐고 스마트폰 앱 개발을 공부해야 됐는데 지금은 거의 개발을 공부 없이도
바이브 코딩 이라는 걸 통해서 어떤 것들을 만들어낼 수가 있는 상황인 거죠. 현재도 어떤 걸 두 가지를 다 생각해보고 싶은데 본질은 무엇이냐
그리고 전망 무엇이냐 라고 생각을 해볼 수가 있는데
제가 이 얘기를 같이 섞어서 좀 할게요. 외주 개발을 짧지만 잠깐 해봤어요. 물론 바이브 코딩으로 좀 했습니다.
생산성이라는 측면에서는 압도하죠. 화면을 1일이 html로 만들고 있으려면 엄청 그것 또한 많은 시간이 걸리죠. css도 그렇고
javascript도 그렇고 모든 다 손이 가요. 당연히 이 백연대 api를 만드는 거 그것도 다 1일이 해줘야 되는 거죠. 물론 어디서 조금씩 붙여 가지고 바꿔서 한다면 좀 낫지만
그래서 개발 좀 해봤던 사람들은 그런 걸 자체가 자체적으로 좀 가지고 있죠. 그래서 그것들을 가지고 활용해서 개발을 좀 더 빨리 할 수 있었는데
지금은 당연히 바이브 코딩으로 좀 더 획기적으로 빨리 할 수 있습니다. 하지만 이제 이런 생각을 해봤어요.
저는 그래서 납품도 하고 어느 정도 잘 돌아갔게끔 하는 과정에서 내가 개발을 아예 몰랐다면 이게 가능했을까 라는 생각 하나
그리고 두 번째는 개발을 몰랐다면 아주 세부적으로 정교하게 만들 수 있을까 라는 생각. 물론 제가 다시 소스를 디버킹하면서 내가 직접 했다라는 의미는 아니에요.
어떤 에라가 나왔을 때 어떻게 처리하고 이런 것들에 대해서는 경험치가 좀 있어서 그런 것들을 바로바로 잡을 수 있었다라는 거
그리고 서버에 올리는 것도 물론 이제 ai가 이런 도움도 주지만 그래도 그 전체 흐르면 알기 때문에 가능한 영역도 분명히 있었다.
그러니까 분명히 바뀐 것도 있고 본질도 있는 것 같아요. 그러니까 지금 본질 얘기를 좀 하고 싶어서 그러는데
바뀐 것과
본질 바뀌지 않은 것
이 무엇인가 생각해보면 바뀐 거는 다분이 코딩인 것 같아요.
내가 html, css, javascript, javaro, api 개발, 지금 이 개발 거는 노드 제이수를 했는데 노드 제이수된 개발 이런 것들을
직접 코딩하지는 않았다 라는 것은 바뀌었죠.
근데 본질은 뭐냐면 이 개발을 하는 진행을 하는 것
그리고 문제 해결을 하는 것
이런 것들 아울러서 요구사항을 만들어 내는 것
이런 것들
개발이라는 것은 어쩌면 원래부터 문제 해결 또는 요구사항을 만들어 주는 것이었을지 모른다.
근데 사실 그것이죠.
윈도우 프로그램이 됐든 도스 프로그램이 됐든 스마트폰 앱이 됐든 만들고자 하는 것을 만들어야 하는 것이 개발자 역할입니다.
원래 본질적으로 근데 어떤 언어로 만들었냐 사실은 고객은 그렇게까지 관심이 없어요.
그리고 시장도 그렇게까지 관심이 없어요. 빨리 나오면 되고 정확히 나오면 되고 잘 되면 돼요.
그렇기 때문에 어떤 언어로 만들과도 사실 개발하는 입장에서는 굉장히 관심이 많고 가끔 그런 얘기 하거든요.
어떤 언어로 개발을 해놨는데 예를 들면 rekt, native로 개발을 했는데 이거를 굳이 플러터로 바꿔야 됩니다.
이런 얘기를 할 때 사실 고객은 이해할 수 없어요.
그래서 근데 이제 개발하려고 하는 개발자가 좀 익숙하거나 이 앱이 되게 플러터에 맞는 앱이다 이럴 수도 있지만 형태가 결국 9시 동일하다면 어떤 언어로 했냐는 별로 관심 없어요.
또 굉장히 어렵게 만들었다 그것도 한 별로 관심 없어요. 그냥 어떻게 보면 잘 만들면 되는 거예요.
잘 만드는 쪽으로 계속 진화해 왔고 지금이 그것에 어떻게 보면 굉장히 많이 발전한 그리고 앞으로도 더 많이 발전할 수 있는 단계라고 볼 수 있는 거죠.
그래서 그렇다면 이 본질을 해결해야 되는 사람 그러니까 본질을 할 사람들은 필요한가 필요하죠.
왜냐하면 예를 들면 이 고객님도 본인이 할 수 있었으면 막기지 않겠죠.
바이브코딩이 굉장히 대중화되고 많은 사람들이 써보고 잘 된다고 하겠지만 어 되네 라고 다 느끼고 있지만
막상 딱 정확한 요구사항을 정교하게 만들기까지는 꽤 많은 시행차구가 있다. 시행차구는 반드시 있습니다.
바이브코딩이라고 해도 이 요구상을 딱 넣었을 때 한 번에 단박에 딱 원하는 걸 정확하게 된다 그렇게 보이진 않아요.
굉장히 많은 반복을 통해서 그것을 정교하게 만들어온 과정이 있어요.
그것이 어떻게 보면 개발자가 또 해야 될 역할 중에 하나인 거고 그리고 그 요구상을 정확히 전달하는 과정도 필요한 거고
그러니까 도구로서는 굉장히 진화 됐지만 결국 도구를 사용해서 만드는 것은 여전히도 필요하다.
물론 얼마큼 획기적이 되면 이 외주를 맡긴 사람이 직접 바이브코딩에다 되고 이것을 직접 만들 수 있는 그 상황이 올 수도 있죠.
그래서 이 본질이 바뀌느냐 개발자의 본질이 바뀌느냐 개발자의 생산성이 향상되느냐
현재는 개발자의 생산성이 극뛰됐다 라고 보이는 시점이 저는 가장 적합한 것 같고
비정공자나 개발을 잘 모르는 코딩을 잘 모르지만 어느 정도 프로타입 수준 아니면 간단한 앱은 만들 수 있다 라고 볼 수 있죠.
하지만 그것을 상용화할 수 있느냐 서비스로 만들 수 있느냐 또는 그것을 납품할 수 있느냐의 문제는 조금 다를 수 있다 라는 정도인 상황인 것 같아요.
그러면 실리콘 벨리도 그렇고 우리나라도 그렇고 개발자 대부분 바이브코딩으로 많이 활용을 하는데
이때 그리고 앞으로 미래 본질이 바뀔 것인가 그리고 미래는 어떤 개발자 필요한가 이런 걸 생각해볼 수 있겠죠.
과거에 뭔가 프레이머 하나에 또는 뭐 그 뭐 html 자바스크립트 같은 거에 굉장히 능숙한 그러니까 어떻게 보면 개발자가 하나에
전문영역은 필요하겠지만 어떤 코딩의 스킬을 굉장히 높이기 위한 달련 이런 것은 어떻게 보면 많은 부분
이제 ai 도움을 받는 것이 훨씬 효율적이 될 수 있는 상황인 거고 그것을 잘 여권하는 일
그리고 어떻게 구현할 것인가에 대한 생각 이런 것들이 개발자에게 여전히 필요한 어떤 능력이지 않을까
그러니까 그게 아키텍처가 될 수도 있는 거고요. 개발을 좀 아는 사람 개발을 좀 공부한 사람 입장에서는 어떻게 개발하면 될지에 윤곽을 좀 잡을 수가 있어요.
그게 어떻게 보면 개발 공부였고 프로젝트를 한번 해본 사람들이 시야가 생기는 거죠.
그러면 ai를 활용해서 그것을 단계적으로 진행하면 수월하게 일이 진행이 되는 거죠.
하지만 아무것도 모른 채로 만약에 ai 에게 그대로 모든 것을 맡긴다면
어느 정도의 결과가 나오겠지만 내가 제외할 수 없는 상황으로 빠질 수도 있고 무한 반복 오류가 생길 수도 있고
그리고 내가 원하지 않는 형태가 나올 수도 있는 거에요.
그래서 여전히 두 가지인 것 같아요.
본질은 여기에 정리한 이런 것들 개발을 진척시켜야 된다 문제를 해결해야 된다 요구상을 결국 만들어내는 것이 개발의 본질이다.
어떤 특정 언어가 아니었다라는 거에요.
코딩만 잘하는 사람이 개발자일 수 있지만 개발업의 본질은 거보단 더 큰 범이고 지금도 동일하고 과거도 동일했다는 거에요.
원하는 것들을 만들어 주는 행위 자체 그것이 개발인 거고 앞으로도 있을 것이냐 당연히 있을 거라고 생각합니다.
개발이라는 업이 없어지진 않아요. 대체될 순이 있겠죠.
그런데 이것이 100% 대체되냐 또 어떤 식으로 대체되냐에 따라서 어떤 사람들이 조금 더 롱런할 수 있고 어떤 사람은 좀 더 한계가 있을 수 있는데
저는 예를 들면 앱을 만든다 또는 서버를 만든다 했을 때 이왕이면 전체에 대한 사이클을 아는 것이 지금은 훨씬 유리하지 않을까 라는 생각이 듭니다.
그래서 앱의 화면부터 시작해서 앱에서 어떤 기능들 그리고 그것이 APL 호출이 돼서 서버에서 어떻게 되고 디비어 어떻게 제작되고 이런 전체를 좀 아는 것이 훨씬 더 유리한 개발자가 될 것이고요.
그리고 AI에 대해서 저는 다양한 이라고 가진 얘기하기는 좀 잘 모르겠어요.
그러니까 솔직히 AI 툴을 다 써봤냐 저는 이런 것보다는 특정 도구를 가지고 클로드도 좋고 커스도 좋고 JGPD도 좋고 어느 걸로든 나만의 무기를 만들고 있느냐.
그러니까 내가 최적화에서 쓸 수 있는 도구가 되어 가느냐. 그리고 그것이 내가 원하는 것들을 만들어낼 수 있다면 정말 더 많은 지금 새로 막 나오고 있는 거에 다 섭외하기는 좀 힘들 것 같아요.
왜냐하면 모두가 다 지쳐요. 지쳐 있어요. 지금 AI 도구에 지쳐 있어요. 너무 새로운 것이 너무 빨리빨리 나오고 너무 새로운 것이 나오기 때문에 이걸 다 따라잡는다.
저는 이거의 한계가 있다고 봅니다. 제 주간이지만 그래서 어떤 거든 내가 좀 특화시켜서 내가 정말 입맛에 맞게 그것을 통해서 만들어낼 수만 있다면 정말 좋은 도구로 사용할 수 있는 그런 개발자가 되는 것이고
또 하나는 해보신 분은 아시겠지만 이 바이브 코딩이라고 해서 그냥 단발이 끝나지 않습니다. 그냥 그것을 어떤 식으로 정교하게 만들어 갔냐라는 것을 자꾸 해보는 것도 한 좀 필요한 것 같아요.
그런 것에 대한 경험치가 쌓이는 것도 되게 중요한 이제는 경험이자 지식인 것 같습니다. 그래서 어떤 식으로 해봤다. 어떤 식으로 연결해 가지고
예를 들면 커서를 쓸 때 어떤 식의 반복을 통해서 정교하게 했다. 문제를 해결했다. 그리고 그것들을 써보에 어떤 식으로 배포했다. 이런 경험치들이 좀 쌓여서
그 경험치가 한 번만 좀 제대로 전체 사이클을 가지고 있다면 또 다른 것도 충분히 만들 수 있는 거죠. 그래서 저는 이제
앞으로 준비를 할 예정인데 바이브 코딩 관련된 영상 또 강의 뭐 책 이런 것도 좀 준비를 하고 있습니다. 그래서 결국은 우리가 부딪혀야 될 부분이고 어떻게 보면 우리 거스로 만들어야 되는 상황이라고 보여줍니다.
그러니까 뭐 당연히 바이브 코딩이 맞냐 틀리냐는 이제 끝난 얘기인 것 같고 활용을 누가 어떻게 잘하냐의 게임에 들어갈 거라고 생각하기 때문에
충분히 지금 많이 활용해서 자기의 개발의 어떤 생산성을 높이는 쪽으로 연구하고 시도해 보면 좋을 것 같습니다.
그래서 저는 앞으로 뭐 영상 바이브 코딩 영상도 좀 올리고 그다음에 강의 강의도 올리고 그리고 책도 지금 준비를 하고 있는데 이런 식으로 좀 함께 할 생각입니다.
그래서 이제는 또 변해야 되는 그러니까 저는 뭐 청공카드까지는 아니지만 최소한 도수 풀그림부터 했던 세대로써 요세대를 거치고
5분 만에 윈도우에서 메뉴가 붙은 화면이 만들어진 거 보면서 충격이었는데 그 충격을 지나서 이게 스마트폰 앱을 지나서 이런 AI의 웨이브에 또 한 번 다시 도전해보고자 합니다.
그러니까 스마트폰 앱이 나왔을 때도 흥분해가지고 여러 가지 앱을 만들어 보면서 좀 시도해 봤는데 지금은 훨씬 더 쉽게 만들 수 있는 시대여서 해보고자 하는 것들을 하나씩 하나씩 해보려고 합니다.
관련해서 뭐 질문이나 같이 공유할 만한 것들이 있으면 같이 남겨주시면 저도 의견도 드리고 제가 아는 부분 답변도 드리고 하겠습니다.
다만 바이브 코딩 시대 그리고 바이브 코딩이라고 해서 개발을 몰라도 된다 저는 그렇게 생각하지 않고 그렇게 말하지도 않습니다.
개발은 공부하면 할수록 저는 좋다고 생각하고 다만 이런 거를 해보다가 해보다가 제가 이제 기술로트의 pdf 도서 때도 강조를 드렸지만
탑다운 식으로 그러니까 전체를 좀 지도처럼 쭉 이해하고 하나씩 하나씩 세부적으로 공부하는 것이 훨씬 유리한 시대가 아닌가
그러니까 자바책 하나를 가지고 막 6개월씩 공부하고 저는 이렇게 해서는 지금 시대를 따라하기 좀 어렵다고 보고요.
자발 기반으로 뭔가를 만들어 보면서 거기서 나오는 에라라든가 거기서 나오는 여러 가지 키워드를 보면서 아 이건 뭐지 라고
뭐 체치피티를 통해서 활용해서 물어본다든지 하는 식으로 알아가는 것이 훨씬 지식 습득이 좋을 것 같아요.
예전에 사전 찾아가면서 공부했고 어른들은 지금도 사전 찾는 것이 훨씬 좋다고 하지만 그것이 좋을 수도 있지만 지금 컴퓨터 찾으면 훨씬 빠르죠.
AI 물어보면 훨씬 빠르죠. 빠르게 얻을 수 있는 것을 최대한 활용하는 것이 좋은 시대이기 때문에 얼마든지 지금 공부할 수 있는 것이 다 갖춰지는 시대입니다.
그래서 시도해 보시고 자기가 상상한 것을 만들어 보시고 그것을 포토폴리오도 만들어 보고 자기가 서비스도 만들어 보고 충분히 가능한 시대다 라고 생각합니다.
제가 조만간 이러한 영상으로 찾아뵙고 또 강의로도 찾아뵙도록 하겠습니다. 감사합니다.